un abuelo cherokee le está contando a
sus nietos que en su interior ocurre una
batalla terrible entre dos lobos un lobo
es la luz es la esperanza es el amor es
el optimismo son las ganas de salir
adelante esa convicción de que no
importan las circunstancias el mundo
puede hacerse mejor si no trabaja con
esmero si se compromete el otro lobo es
la oscuridad es la tristeza es la
desesperanza es el odio es ese pesimismo
que convence a las personas de que no
importan las oportunidades el mundo
simplemente va a ser cada vez peor
naturalmente un nieto preguntaba una
nieta preocupada le va a decir abuelo
cuál no cuándo va a ganar esa batalla y
un abuelo lleno de ternura y el cariño
con mucha sabiduría le va a decir hijo
mío va a ganar el lobo que tu alimento
estamos viendo la época de muchos
cambios una época en la que las nuevas
tecnologías
literalmente dis rompen lo que se ha
discutido en el pasado y nos traen
nuevas instrucciones constantemente
tecnologías como la impresión 3d
tecnologías como el análisis de big data
los datos abiertos la genómica de última
generación pero sobre todo la
inteligencia artificial vienen haciendo
estragos en la estructura de la forma de
pensamiento alrededor de la sociedad de
la política de la economía y vemos que
hay una tendencia negativa eso no es
nuevo eso ha pasado antes lo que vemos
hoy lo que experimentamos hoy como
tensiones entre diferentes elementos de
la sociedad frente a cómo reaccionar a
los cambios muchas voces llamando a
retomar ideas del pasado y plantear las
como si fueran ideas novedosas eso
también ha sucedido en el pasado hace
dos siglos los luditas se opusieron a la
revolución industrial destruían máquinas
creaban movimientos sociales fueron la
primera forma de
si se quiere como de revoluciones
modernas que causaron daños alrededor
del mundo y también forzar algunos
cambios importantes pero lo cierto es
que la tecnología no discrimina entre
formas de pensar no discrimina entre
razas no discrimina entre ideologías no
es quinientas religiones entre
orientaciones sexuales
la tecnología tiene la lógica que
simplemente va hacia adelante y depende
de nosotros con qué actitud nos
enfrentamos y de qué manera construimos
alrededor de ella así un poco más de un
siglo también hubo un momento de tensión
nuevamente no solamente la gente estaba
entrando en procesos de educación masiva
alfabetizándose había nuevos medios la
televisión la radio el cine se
convirtieron en el foro global de
intercambio cultural y hubo quienes de
manera anticipada aprovechar los
espacios estos tres personajes tienen
muchas cosas en común
historias de genocidio crímenes de lesa
humanidad
dictadores regímenes totalitarios que
causaban enorme daño adicionalmente los
tres fueron candidatos al premio nobel
de paz un tema importante a tener en
cuenta con respecto a esto es la
confusión que se causa sobre los valores
y los principios cuando el orden está
cambiando cuando los paradigmas se están
cambiando es por eso que es importante
que actuemos con convicción con
optimismo que alimentemos el nuevo
adecuado para que para que el resultado
de nuestros tiempos no vaya a ser otro
periodo oscuro otro periodo dificultades
tenemos que creer entonces en un futuro
y para ello tenemos que ser creativos
tenemos que entender
es en la cultura es en la creatividad es
en nuestra identidad donde reside la
respuesta no es en los falsos paradigmas
que nos plantean los profetas del pasado
como dijo en su momento
frank general nos ve con respecto al
nuevo orden de hitler hay no hay nada
nuevo y no es ningún orden se trata
entonces de crear de entender que es en
los creativos en los cultores en los
gestores del patrimonio en los
protectores de nuestras tradiciones
donde encontramos la inspiración para
precisamente ser fuertes y
transformarnos para que el entorno el
entorno que transforma con la humanidad
tres cosas que les voy a contar lo
primero un cambio que tiene que ser muy
importante y es el cambio al real
alrededor
de de ser es decir
es el cambio alrededor de darle sentido
a la cultura ahí vemos la frase de de
benedetti una frase muy linda parte del
problema que en el mundo que vivimos es
que creíamos que todo lo teníamos
resuelto
si ustedes preguntan a las grandes
compañías entretenimiento hace 20 años
dos jóvenes les cambiaron todas las
preguntas si se han demorado casi dos
décadas en encontrar nuevas respuestas
aquí lo importante es que entendamos que
tenemos que mantenernos con los pies en
la tierra eso qué quiere decir tenemos
que entender que si creemos en el
talento de la gente podemos encontrar
respuestas estos son los jóvenes de la
orquesta instrumentos reciclados del
paraguay estos son jóvenes que provienen
del barrio más pobre de asunción un
tiradero basuras fabio chávez el creador
de la orquesta instrumentos reciclados
de cateura que es el nombre del barrio
desde decía el mundo nos tira basuras y
nosotros le respondemos con cultura a lo
que voy con esto es que estos jóvenes
que ustedes ven en esa pantalla junto a
otros jóvenes que han hecho parte de
este proceso han dado conciertos en más
de 50 países del mundo más de mil
ocasiones en los campos inspirar a
cientos de miles de personas eso no es
un logro menor han sido teloneros de
metallica
y si ustedes comparan la experiencia
estos jóvenes a través de vivir la
cultura a partir de practicar un arte
con disciplina con trabajo en equipo que
tenemos ahí tenemos las nuevas
habilidades tenemos habilidades blandas
que les permiten desarrollar en
desarrollar disciplina resiliencia
entender que no es un camino fácil el de
apostarle a la cultura pero sobre todo
aprenden que tienen un valor que está
por encima de donde nacieron y con qué
recursos y oportunidades cuentan al
inicio de sus vidas
estos jóvenes conocen más mundo que la
mayoría la gente más prolija del planeta
pero solamente lo conocen han sido
celebrados y vitoreados tuve la
oportunidad de ser testigo de uno de
esos momentos en el kennedy center en
washington frente a la comunidad
internacional de diplomáticos y de
miembros de el gobierno de los eeuu y de
la banca multilateral y fue
absolutamente emocionante ver como
llegado el mensaje de la música y unos
jóvenes que nacían sin esperanza pero
que estaban transformando el mundo
lo segundo es entender que si bien el
mundo en el que vivimos en su mundo de
elementos sólidos de infraestructuras
que hay que seguir trabajando las
infraestructuras son el mecanismo a
través del cual nosotros podemos
efectivamente nivelar la cancha proveer
oportunidades de acceso a través de la
conectividad a través de los escenarios
y todo eso
'el principito' nos recuerda que tenemos
que mirar más allá de lo que los ojos
pueden ver tenemos que ver con los ojos
del corazón y esto quiere decir entender
que la infraestructura tiene que tener
una dimensión humana el caso de seúl es
paradigmático probablemente sea la
ciudad más inteligente hoy en el mundo
es una ciudad comprometida con la
transformación de sus entornos si están
instalando en este momento más de 50.000
nuevos sensores para mejorar el
transporte de la recolección de basura
el flujo de los servicios públicos la
seguridad del espacio público en fin
están haciendo todo lo necesario para
que los ciudanos se conecten ante los
sistemas de pago gratuito en términos de
para activar pequeños comercios en los
locales creo que tienen como todas las
acciones que tiene que tiene según tiene
que el individuo está en el centro de
estrategia están construyendo todas sus
estrategias
alrededor de las tradiciones locales
alrededor de las economías locales
alrededor de la identidad de cada barrio
para esto no lo han hecho de manera
fortuita hace 20 años crearon una
agencia dedicada a la transformación de
la ciudad es decir es una transición con
intención sin invertir muchos más
recursos tal vez menos que muchas otras
ciudades que intentan ser inteligentes
están logrando transformaciones
profundas nuevamente el elemento central
el hilo conductor de esa transformación
en infraestructura que da acceso al
intercambio y a la actividad pues
particular que permite vivir con
dignidad está en el comprender el valor
de la cultura de la identidad y del
simbolismo y pues un tercer alma esa
dimensión en la dimensión de las
instituciones
bruce lee a quienes recuerda que no es
solamente pensar en cómo es que nosotros
nos sentimos frente al mundo con qué
actitud enfrentamos es entender que
tenemos que estar atentos a actuar
atentos a evolucionar en este sentido
los invito a conocer la historia de town
house town house es un proyecto que
nació en egipto en el año 1998 en un
barrio del cairo un barrio en una zona
sin sin ley una zona abandonada un joven
norteamericano lleno de energía lleno de
sueños se encontró con una casa averiguó
quien el dueño de la casa esa casa
abandonada pertenecía al ministerio de
cultura el comienzo es algo muy
interesante evolucionar las
instituciones en lugar de decir alguien
debería hacer algo para restaurar esa
casa él asume el reto de convencer al
ministerio de tener una oportunidad
administrando este espacio inició el
proceso con la creación de unas
residencias artísticas para que artistas
jóvenes europeos
en temporadas de 4 a 6 meses a esa casa
y se juntaran con artistas locales
hoy por hoy docenas de artistas europeos
y norteamericanos han pasado por tan
house han interactuado con docenas de
artistas egipcios han creado movimientos
enteros festivales de fotografía
festivales de arte festivales de danza
pero solamente eso han transformado el
adn que componía este barrio este un
barrio donde donde pululaban el delito
donde había traficantes de drogas con el
tiempo los talleres de mecánica que
existe alrededor fueron diciendo sabe
que yo dejé este proceso y a la casa se
fueron sumando bodegas y otros espacios
hoy por hoy lo que tenemos allí es un
centro cultural que viene desde las
bases y que ha transformado el sentido
de ese barrio es uno de los barrios más
interesantes hoy en día es un barrio que
puede comunicar esperanza es un barrio y
construye oportunidades es un barrio que
le muestra al mundo que no solamente
las inversiones que puedas el estado
también puede hacerse un esfuerzo de lo
privado y sumar las instituciones que
necesitamos hoy no sólo lo público o lo
privado eso es un falso dilema es la
actuación conjunta alrededor de un
propósito común y es que la cultura debe
estar en el centro de esta estrategia
desarrollo es así que entonces los dejo
con una pregunta para reflexionar y es
ustedes que luego están alimentando
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]